are you a dragon ball fan do you own a  3ds if you answered yes to both  questions I've got the game for you I'm  Tony and this is your super saiyan  gamespot news update dragonball fusions  launched in japan earlier this year but  it's finally making its way to the rest  of the world fusion starts two new  characters called TECA and pinnock sent  to a world that mixes the timelines and  planets of the Dragon Ball universe the  duo explores this strange new world  recruiting classic characters and fusing  them into more powerful fighters the  whole thing is done in a chibi art style  painting heroes like Goku Vegeta and  Krillin with a cutesy new look  Dragonball fusions comes to 3ds in north  america on december 13th of this year  and in europe in February 2017 there's  no shortage of dragon ball games out  there but this looks like an adorable  fresh take on accurate or Yama's classic  to keep up with all the DBZ game news  you're already in the right place  you